in drawn to death a restless  high-schoolers artistic imagination  comes to life in this multiplayer  shooter brawler its art style emulates  the unrefined look of notebook doodles  in all its ballpoint ink glory it's due  out april 4th exclusively on the  playstation 4 for $19.99 and it'll be  free if you have a PlayStation Plus  subscription and if you enjoyed this  collection of gameplay highlights give  us a like subscribe to our YouTube  channel and check out GameSpot calm  thanks for watching  [Applause]  [Music]  someone has a dog I'm glad it is you  stay dead you freak and stay the [ __ ]  away from our family  [Music]  [Music]  match complete your team is victorious I  get zero joy taking lives but I ain't  gonna lie first place feels great